Rod Hudson grew up on a dairy farm in New Hampshire and worked the farm from the time he was big enough to help out, six, seven years old. When his father retired, Rod ran his own operation on his dad's property and did just fine until the mid 1980's when something strange started to happen with the cows. A series of strange things started to happen actually, beginning with their hooves...
罗德·哈德森在新罕布什尔州的一个奶牛场长大，从六七岁大、能帮忙干活起，他就一直在农场里工作。他父亲退休后，罗德就在他父亲的产业上经营自己的业务，一切都进行得很顺利，直到1980年代中期，奶牛身上开始出现了一些奇怪的事情。实际上，一系列奇怪的事情接踵而至，最先是从它们的蹄子开始的……
That was the first thing. Cow's feet don't normally have to be trimmed only about once a year, possibly twice. And I was having to trim them three and four times a year.
那是第一件事。奶牛的蹄子通常一年只需要修剪一次，或者两次。而我却不得不一年给它们修剪三到四次。
Do you mean just trim their hooves.
你是说仅仅是修剪它们的蹄子吗？
Right. If they get sore feet, they don't walk around like they should. They won't go and eat like they should.
对。如果它们的脚感到疼痛，它们就不会像正常那样走动。它们也不会像正常那样去吃东西。
Do they give as much milk?
它们的产奶量会减少吗？
No, no. The production was low all the time.
不，不会。产量一直很低。
A healthy cow would give Rod 75 90 pounds of milk a day. These cows were averaging 40 at best. It was hard to even cover expenses. The cows developed other problems. They had trouble conceiving. They started losing weight. They began to get sick.
一头健康的奶牛每天能给罗德提供75到90磅的牛奶。这些奶牛平均产奶量最好也就40磅。甚至连成本都难以维持。奶牛还出现了其他问题。它们难以受孕。它们开始消瘦。它们开始生病。
Oh, I'd have a veterinarian in about every six weeks or something like that.
哦，我大约每六周左右就得请一次兽医，诸如此类的。
Was that pretty expensive?
那很贵吗？
It's very expensive. You could spend $100 per cow pretty quick. And all I'd get out of them is they didn't know what was the matter with them.
非常贵。你很快就能在一头牛身上花掉100美元。而我从他们那得到的答复仅仅是，他们不知道它们出了什么毛病。
They tried medicines. They changed the cow's feed. They'd change it again. They replaced the cows with new cows. And this went on, month after month, year after year, for a decade and a half. And Rod was not a novice. He was an experienced dairy farmer who'd been through a lot, nearly 50 years old when the troubles began. He tried this. He tried that, all the time watching himself slowly go broke.
他们尝试过药物。他们改变了奶牛的饲料。他们又再次更换。他们用新奶牛替换了旧奶牛。这种情况持续了，一个月又一个月，一年又一年，整整十五年。而罗德并非新手。他是一位经验丰富的奶农，经历过很多事情，当这些麻烦开始时，他已经快50岁了。他试了这个，试了那个，时刻眼睁睁看着自己慢慢破产。
Well, just nobody had any answers. They'd make suggestions, and we'd try to do what was suggested to us. And nothing seemed to work for us at all.
嗯，只是没有人能给出答案。他们会提出建议，我们也尝试去做建议我们做的事。但似乎没什么对我们有效。
It just must have made you feel so crazy.
这一定让你觉得很抓狂。
Well, I blamed it onto myself as much as anything. I tried to accept the fact that I wasn't doing something right. And as they, no matter what I did, it didn't work.
嗯，我像责怪其他任何事情一样责怪我自己。我试着接受这样一个事实：我有些事情做得不对。正如他们所说，无论我做什么，都不奏效。
The first time I talked to Rod a few months back, someone that I'm close to was having all sorts of medical problems and going through tests, and CAT scans, and spinal taps, and more CAT scans. And the doctors couldn't figure out what was causing the problems. And in the absence of information, she did what Rod did. She blamed yourself. And I think this happens a lot. I think that when you have nothing to go on, you fill the vacuum with anything that you have at hand, with any superstitions that you can think of, with everything that you think you could have done wrong. Before something has a name, it could be anything. And that period before you know the truth, that period is often worse than the truth that you find out.
几个月前我第一次和罗德交谈时，我身边的一个亲近的人也正面临各种各样的健康问题，经历着各种检查、CAT扫描、脊髓穿刺，以及更多的CAT扫描。医生们找不出问题的根源。在信息缺失的情况下，她做了罗德做过的事。她责怪自己。我认为这种情况经常发生。我认为，当你毫无头绪时，你会用手边的一切、你能想到的任何迷信、你认为自己可能做错的每一件事来填补这个空白。在某样东西有了名字之前，它可能是任何东西。而在你知道真相之前的那个阶段，那个时期往往比你最终发现的真相还要糟糕。
Today on our program, we bring you stories about that eerie, unsettling period before something has a name, and stories about how things change once things do have a name. In Rod's case, it turned out that high voltage power lines that crossed his property were leaking current into the ground. When it was wet outside, moisture would carry the electricity-- not much electricity, just 35 watts or so, enough for a vibration sort of feeling-- through the ground, and into the barn and up into the cows drinking trough.
今天在我们的节目中，我们为您带来关于那个在某样东西有了名字之前令人毛骨悚然、不安的时期的故事，以及关于一旦事物有了名字后情况如何改变的故事。在罗德的案例中，事实证明，穿过他土地的高压输电线正在向地下漏电。当外面潮湿时，水分会传导电流——虽然电流不大，大约只有35瓦左右，但足以产生一种震动感——通过地面，进入牛棚，一直传到奶牛的饮水槽里。
The cow was standing there with bare feet in a wet spot. Then they go to drink the water, and because this electricity was getting into the water, why they'd get a shock as they were drinking.
奶牛赤着脚站在湿地上。然后它们去喝水，由于电流进入了水中，所以它们在喝水时会受到电击。
And would that do?
那会怎么样呢？
Well, instead of putting their head down into the water and drinking it, they were just lapping at it like a dog laps water. And they just wouldn't take in that much. They were afraid they were going to get a shock when they'd go to drink.
嗯，它们不再把头伸进水里喝水，而是像狗喝水一样舔着喝。它们就是喝不下多少水。它们害怕去喝水时会遭到电击。
The cows were dehydrated, getting only about a third of the water they were supposed to get. And that explained all of their other problems. After nearly 15 years of uncertainty, it was a relief to finally know the answer. But Rod Hudson was so heavily in debt, there was no way to recoup fast enough, and he lost the farm. At 65, he now has a new job.
奶牛脱水了，摄入的水量只有它们应得的三分之一。这就解释了它们所有其他的问题。在经历了近15年的不确定性之后，终于知道答案真是一种解脱。但罗德·哈德森背负着沉重的债务，根本无法快速回本，他失去了农场。65岁时，他现在有了一份新工作。
At the present time, I'm driving for Thomas Transportation out of Keene. That's an airport shuttle service. And I'm putting in somewhere around 50 to 60 hours a week.
目前，我在基恩为托马斯运输公司开车。那是一家机场班车服务公司。我每周大约工作50到60个小时。
And you do the early morning?
你负责清晨的时段吗？
I do basically early morning runs.
我基本上负责清晨的班次。
Starting around when?
大约从什么时候开始？
Generally, it's around 3:00 or half past.
通常是3点或者3点半左右。
So even earlier than you would have to get up to milk cows?
所以比你以前挤奶起床的时间还要早？
Well, just about the same time.
嗯，差不多是同一个时间。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah, because that's about the time that I normally god up.
是的，因为那差不多是我通常起床的时间。
And so what do you think of that job?
那你觉得那份工作怎么样？
I love it.
我喜欢它。
You do?
你真的喜欢？
I really do.
我真的很喜欢。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Before It Had a Name. Our program in four acts today.
嗯，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是《在它拥有名字之前》。今天我们的节目分为四幕。
Act One, Mr. Boder Vanishes. In that act, the very first recordings of Holocaust survivors made just after the war before the Holocaust was even called the Holocaust, and very different from other Holocaust survivor interviews because of that. Forgotten for decades, never before broadcast, those tapes here today on our program. And the story of the man who collected them.
第一幕，《博德先生消失了》。在这一幕中，战后刚录制的关于大屠杀幸存者的最初录音，那时大屠杀甚至还没被称为“大屠杀”，正因如此，它们与后来其他大屠杀幸存者的采访截然不同。这些磁带被遗忘了数十年，从未被播出过，今天将在我们的节目中播放。还有那位收集这些磁带的人的故事。
Act Two, Of Course I Remember Your Name. In that act, the difference between those we know and those whose names we now.
第二幕，《当然，我记得你的名字》。在这一幕中，我们所认识的人和那些我们仅知晓其名的人之间的区别。
Act Three, A Bad Day For Plates, the story of four kids who that their mother was just mean. And then, they found out that there was a different name for it completely, rewriting everything they ever knew about her.
第三幕，《盘子倒霉的一天》，关于四个认为他们的母亲只是刻薄的孩子的故事。然后，他们发现对于这种情况有一个完全不同的定义，这重写了他们对她所知的一切。
Act Four, You Call That Love? Stay with us.
第四幕，《你管那叫爱？》。请继续收听。
Act One, Mr. Boder vanishes. This is the story of a man named David Boder, who started to investigate the Holocaust before it was known as the Holocaust. And because of that, his research was different, and treated differently by the world, than investigations done later. Carl Marziali tells the story.
第一幕，《博德先生消失了》。这是一个名叫大卫·博德的人的故事，他开始调查大屠杀时，它还没被称为“大屠杀”。正因如此，他的研究与后来进行的调查不同，也受到世人不同的对待。卡尔·马齐亚利讲述了这个故事。
In 1946, David Boder went to Europe to interview survivors of Nazi concentration camps, specifically to record their stories in their own voices. At the time, this was a new idea, so new he was the only one who went. What he got were the first oral histories of Holocaust survivors before it was even called the Holocaust. Even if you've heard other survivor accounts, there's something different about these interviews. Over and over, people refer to names that have since taken on a bigger significance, but without knowing the bigger significance.
1946年，大卫·博德前往欧洲采访纳粹集中营的幸存者，专门用他们自己的声音录下他们的故事。在当时，这是一个新想法，新到他是唯一一个这么做的人。他得到的是第一手大屠杀幸存者的口述历史，当时甚至还没人称之为大屠杀。即使你听过其他幸存者的叙述，这些采访中也有一些与众不同的地方。人们反复提到那些后来具有更大意义的名字，但他们却不知道其更大的意义。
George Caldor, a survivor from Hungary, tells Boder that when he first arrived at the camp, he walked past a gate with the words, "Work Sets Man Free," and met an SS chief physician whose name Boder didn't recognize and misspelled on the transcript as Wengele. Boder typed question marks next to the name. When a French woman named Nellie Bandy mentions the camp she was sent to, it's not enough for her to say the names Birkenau and Auschwitz for Boder to know what she's talking about.
匈牙利幸存者乔治·卡尔多告诉博德，当他第一次到达集中营时，他经过了一道写着“劳动带来自由”的门，并遇到了一位纳粹党卫军首席医师，他的名字博德没认出来，并在文字记录中拼写错误为“Wengele”。博德在名字旁边打了问号。当一位名叫内莉·班迪的法国女性提到她被送往的集中营时，对她来说，只说“比克瑙”和“奥斯威辛”这两个名字还不足以让博德知道她在说什么。
Where is that?
那是在哪里？
Birkenau is some kilometers from Auschwitz.
比克瑙距离奥斯威辛几公里远。
And Auschwitz is where?
那奥斯威辛在哪里？
In East Upper Silesia.
在上西里西亚东部。
In East Upper Silesia. Who has it now?
在上西里西亚东部。现在是谁在管理？
Poland.
波兰。
Poland has it now.
波兰现在拥有它。
She tells Boder about the march from Auschwitz to Birkenau, and on the way the guards shot the stragglers, a familiar scene to anyone who's seen a movie or read a book about the Holocaust, but surprising and new to Boder.
她告诉博德关于从奥斯威辛到比克瑙的行军，沿途守卫射杀那些掉队者，这对任何看过关于大屠杀的电影或读过相关书籍的人来说都是熟悉的场景，但对博德来说却是令人惊讶和新鲜的。
What were they, shooting them like sentenced people, putting them to the wall?
他们是什么情况，像处决犯人一样枪杀他们，把他们推向墙边吗？
Oh no [INAUDIBLE]
哦不，[听不清]
Oh no, she's saying. She fell down somewhere and he just shot at her. That was all.
哦不，她说。她不知在哪跌倒了，他就只是向她开枪。仅此而已。
All the route was bordered with corpses, you see.
整条路上都堆满了尸体，你明白吗。
All the route was bordered with corpses, you see?
整条路上都堆满了尸体，你明白吗？
And whose corpses were that?
那那些是谁的尸体？
Well, there were men who had been led before us and had been shot like that.
嗯，那是先于我们被带走并那样被枪杀的人。
There were men who had been before us and had been shot like that. Maybe it's a kind of dramatic irony, the ratio of our own awareness to the speaker's lack of it. Maybe it's the way people talk when they barely know what's happened to them, before analysis and judgment show up to put everything in its place. The people in the camps had been cut off from almost all news reports for years, so all they can talk about is what happened to them. They have no bigger picture. When Nellie Bandy tires to get refuge with the US Army after the German surrender, she goes to a checkpoint and talks to an American guard.
那是先于我们被带走并那样被枪杀的人。也许这是一种戏剧性的讽刺，源于我们自己的认知与说话者缺乏认知之间的比例。也许这就是人们在几乎不知道自己身上发生了什么时说话的方式，在分析和评判出现并把一切归位之前。集中营里的人们多年来几乎与所有新闻报道隔绝，所以他们只能谈论发生在他们自己身上的事。他们没有更大的全景视野。当内莉·班迪在德国投降后试图向美军寻求避难时，她走到一个检查站并与一名美国卫兵交谈。
I came to see them, and I spoke English. And asked them if I could get over. "Well who are you?"
我来看他们，我说了英语。问他们我是否能过去。“嗯，你是谁？”
When the guard asks here who she is, she can't just say, a Holocaust survivor. The idea doesn't exist for her or the guard. So instead, she makes up a term for herself. I'm a French political prisoner, she says.
当卫兵问她是谁时，她不能直接说“大屠杀幸存者”。这个概念对她或卫兵来说都不存在。所以，她为自己编造了一个术语。我是法国政治犯，她说。
I'm a French political prisoner.
我是法国政治犯。
The guard says he doesn't have any instructions for political prisoners and goes to ask his captain.
卫兵说他没有关于政治犯的指示，便去问他的长官了。
The captain came back [INAUDIBLE]
长官回来[听不清]
The captain comes back and tells her, "I'm extremely sorry, but so far I haven't got any instructions for political prisoners, just for prisoners of war. And turns her away.
长官回来告诉她：“非常抱歉，但到目前为止我还没有收到关于政治犯的指示，只有关于战俘的。”然后把她打发走了。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Often in the recordings, you get the sense of two worlds meeting for the first time and trying to figure each other. The survivors and the people they come across just to speak the same language. This is very different from later interviews with survivors after a common language had developed.
在这些录音中，你经常能感觉到两个世界第一次相遇并试图理解对方。幸存者和他们遇到的人只是在说同一种语言。这与后来在形成共同语言后进行的幸存者采访非常不同。
So they had to go on the so-called death march. You had to keep out because if you fell down, they shot you.
所以他们必须进行所谓的死亡行军。你必须坚持住，因为如果你跌倒了，他们就射杀你。
These are interviews of survivors made after 1988 and released in a boxed set called Voices Of The Shoa. This one describes the same experience Nellie Bandy had, but now it has a name, the death march.
这些是1988年之后制作并发布在一套名为《犹太人大屠杀的声音》的盒装录音带中的幸存者采访。这个录音描述了内莉·班迪经历过同样的体验，但现在它有了一个名字：死亡行军。
We had to march. So my sister is older. She gave me her shoes. It was January, 1945. I was so slippery. I was cold. No food, nothing, that if you slipped, you couldn't get up. There was no way in heaven you could get up. At the beginning, they shot you right on the spot, but after a while, why waste a bullet? Let them freeze to death. That's why they called it the death march.
我们必须行军。所以我姐姐年纪大些。她把鞋子给了我。那是1945年1月。路上太滑了。我很冷。没有食物，什么都没有，如果你滑倒了，你就起不来。天底下根本没法起来。起初，他们当场就射杀你，但过了一阵子，何必浪费一颗子弹呢？让他们冻死吧。这就是为什么他们称之为死亡行军。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
And whose corpses do you think they were?
那你觉得那些是谁的尸体？
They were [UNINTELLIGIBLE] people.
那是[听不清]的人。
Boder recorded 109 interviews over two months. He cut an unlikely figure, an older man in goatee and glasses, wearing a blazer and tie in the middle of summer, burdened by 60 pounds of primitive recording equipment and a bad heart. Because he did this work before the Holocaust had a name, and everything that comes with a name, recognition, context, a common language, he had trouble getting funded. His work was never truly completed. His tapes were lost for decades, and he died in obscurity.
博德在两个月内录制了109次采访。他看起来是个不太可能的人选，一个留着山羊胡、戴着眼镜的老人，在仲夏时节穿着西装外套和领带，背负着60磅重的原始录音设备，心脏也不好。因为他在大屠杀拥有名字之前就做了这项工作，而所有伴随名字而来的东西——认可、背景、共同语言——他都没享受到，导致他在获取资助方面遇到了困难。他的工作从未真正完成。他的磁带被遗失了数十年，他也在默默无闻中去世。
Well, from Buchenwald we went to Auschwitz.
嗯，从布痕瓦尔德我们去了奥斯威辛。
Yes, and from Auschwitz?
是的，那从奥斯威辛之后呢？
And from Auschwitz, we went to a little station [INAUDIBLE]
从奥斯威辛之后，我们去了一个小车站[听不清]
I first came across Boder's name in 1988. I was on a freelance assignment at the Illinois Institute of Technology in Chicago when a professor I knew showed me a copy of a campus magazine from 1947. He'd found it in somebody's attic, started flipping through it, and on page 18, found an article by David P. Boder, a psychology professor at IIT.
我第一次看到博德的名字是在1988年。当时我在芝加哥伊利诺伊理工学院从事自由职业，一位我认识的教授给我看了1947年的一份校园杂志。他在某个人的阁楼里发现的，翻看的时候，在第18页发现了一篇由伊利诺伊理工学院心理学教授大卫·P·博德撰写的文章。
Boder's article was about his recent expedition to Europe, and it struck me as odd for a couple of reasons. I'd never heard of Boder, even though, as it turns out, he was the first person ever to record Holocaust victims. And the tone was odd. His writing was clear, informative and totally devoid of personal content. It seemed strange that a Jewish man who had come face to face with the attempted extinction of his people would title his article, "The Displaced People of Europe, Preliminary Notes on a Psychological and Anthropological Study."
博德的文章是关于他最近的欧洲之行，这让我觉得很奇怪，原因有两个。我从未听说过博德，尽管事实证明，他是第一个录制大屠杀受害者的人。而且语气也很奇怪。他的文笔清晰、信息丰富，完全没有任何个人内容。一个面对自己民族被试图灭绝的犹太人，将文章标题定为《欧洲的流离失所者，关于心理学和人类学研究的初步说明》，这似乎很奇怪。
I decided to find out what I could about David Boder. In the 1930's and '40's, he was a minor public figure, the kind of professor who knew how to get his name in print. He showed up in Time magazine with some invention called "the adjective verb quotient." He made the papers with his analysis of children's letters to Santa Claus, and with an experiment where he wired his students with sensors and charted their reactions to scary movies.
我决定找出关于大卫·博德的一切。在1930年代和40年代，他是一个小人物，那种懂得如何让自己的名字见报的教授。他曾带着一项名为“形容词动词商”的发明出现在《时代》周刊上。他凭借对孩子们写给圣诞老人的信的分析上了报纸，还有一项实验，他给学生装上传感器，记录他们对恐怖电影的反应。
But at some point in the mid '40's, his research shifted focus and took on an urgent tone. By 1945, he was trying to get a visa for Europe and furiously writing grant proposals to fund a project there. There were newsreel and newspaper accounts of what had happened in the camps, but Boder was proposing to interview survivors in their own languages-- he spoke at least seven himself-- and in their own words.
但在40年代中期的某个时候，他的研究重点发生了转移，并带上了一种紧迫的基调。到1945年，他正试图获得去欧洲的签证，并疯狂地撰写资助申请书以资助那里的项目。当时有关于集中营里发生的事情的新闻短片和报纸报道，但博德提议用幸存者自己的语言——他自己至少会说七种——并用他们自己的话来采访他们。
Boder got rejection letters from a who's who of postwar philanthropy, the American Jewish Conference, the Guggenheim Foundation, the B'nai B'rith, the federal government. He kept going, and it wasn't clear to me what was driving him. It seemed to be more than scholarly interest. But among the grant applications, newspaper clippings, boxes and boxes of archival papers, there was not a single personal artifact, no reflections, no memoirs, not one personal note in his travel diary.
博德收到了战后慈善机构名人录的拒信，包括美国犹太人会议、古根海姆基金会、圣约之子会、联邦政府。他继续前进，我不清楚是什么在驱动他。这似乎不仅仅是学术兴趣。但在资助申请、报纸剪报、一箱箱档案文件之间，没有一件个人物品，没有反思，没有回忆录，在他的旅行日记中甚至没有一条个人笔记。
Boder died 40 years ago, and his only daughter, Elena, died childless in 1995. To learn more, actually to learn anything about Boder's private self, I turned to Sylvia Jericho, a lifelong family friend and a colleague of Boder's daughter Elena. According to Sylvia, Boder in person was a lot like Boder in print. He'd go on at great length about psychology or the works of Chekhov.
博德在40年前去世，他唯一的女儿埃琳娜在1995年去世，没有留下孩子。为了了解更多，实际上是为了了解任何关于博德私人生活的事情，我找到了西尔维娅·杰里科，她是博德的女儿埃琳娜的终身家庭朋友和同事。据西尔维娅说，生活中的博德和文章里的博德很像。他会滔滔不绝地谈论心理学或契诃夫的作品。
But I don't remember his ever talking about himself in the world.
但我记得他从来没有谈论过他自己在世界上的经历。
Why do you think that was?
你认为这是为什么？
Well, I think it reflects tragedy in his life, and that he had abandoned his early life. And I think there was a schism between him and his early life.
嗯，我认为这反映了他生活中的悲剧，而且他抛弃了他早年的生活。我认为他和他的早年生活之间存在一条裂痕。
Here are some parts of his early life that Boder might have been trying to abandon. He had married in Russian when he was 20 years old and divorced two years later. I talked to the family historian in Israel, who says that Boder converted to Christianity to get ahead, and that this was the reason his wife left him. Boder fled Russia in 1919 after the Bolshevik Revolution, taking his daughter Elena with him. Some in his wife's family accuse him of abducting Elena, of taking her without the mother's consent.
以下是他早年生活的一些博德可能试图抛弃的部分。他在20岁时在俄罗斯结婚，两年后离婚。我与以色列的一位家族历史学家交谈过，他说博德为了前途皈依了基督教，这就是他妻子离开他的原因。博德在1919年布尔什维克革命后逃离俄罗斯，带着他的女儿埃琳娜一起。他妻子家的一些人指控他绑架了埃琳娜，在未经母亲同意的情况下带走了她。
He also changed his name, so by the time he arrived in Chicago, was no longer David or Pavel Michelson, Latvian Jew, but Dr. David Pablo Boder, scholar without frontiers. Meanwhile, his wife stayed in Latvia, held onto her name and identity and was executed in a ghetto in 1941, just before Boder appeared in Time magazine for his study of adjectives and verbs.
他还改了名字，所以当他到达芝加哥时，他不再是拉脱维亚犹太人大卫或帕维尔·米切尔森，而是学者大卫·巴勃罗·博德。与此同时，他的妻子留在拉脱维亚，保留了她的名字和身份，并于1941年在隔都中被处决，就在博德因为他的形容词和动词研究出现在《时代》杂志上之前。
It's hard to resist the pattern that having betrayed-- that in part, his study of the people of the Holocaust and his determination to get there, and to catch the stories in there purist telling. It's hard to resist the interpretation that in part, this atoned for the freedom from that kind of torment that he achieved by simply leaving.
很难抗拒这样的模式，即他背叛了——在某种程度上，他对大屠杀受害者的研究和他去那里的决心，以及捕捉最纯粹的叙述——很难抗拒这样的解释，即在某种程度上，这弥补了通过简单离开而获得的那种逃避折磨的自由。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
On July 29, 1946, Boder finally made it to Europe. In the end, after more than a year of writing grant proposals, he went without official funding. He had money from his daughter, donations from a few assumptions and a loan from his life insurance. I should point out again just how uninterested the rest of the world was in Boder's idea. The project was a one man effort from start to finish. He worked without translators and operated the equipment on his own, often pausing to untangle wire that bunched up like fishing line. He would show up in a safe house, a refugee camp, ask for volunteers, find a quiet corner and begin his questions.
1946年7月29日，博德终于到了欧洲。最终，在写了一年多的资助申请书后，他在没有官方资助的情况下去了。他有来自女儿的钱、一些假设的捐款，还有他的人寿保险贷款。我应该再次指出，世界其他地方对博德的想法是多么不感兴趣。这个项目从头到尾是一个人的努力。他没有翻译，独自操作设备，经常停下来解开像鱼线一样缠在一起的电线。他会出现在安全屋、难民营，寻求志愿者，找个安静的角落，开始他的提问。
Munich, Germany, September 20, 1946. The spool is at nine minutes. The interview is [? Mr. Jurgen Bassfruend 22 years old. [SPEAKING GERMAN]
德国慕尼黑，1946年9月20日。线盘已录制九分钟。采访对象是尤尔根·巴斯弗罗恩德先生，22岁。[说德语]
[SPEAKING GERMAN]
[说德语]
Jurgen Bassfreund now goes by Jack Bass. He lives in Birmingham, Alabama where I went to talk to him about the old professor he met while waiting to leave Europe.
尤尔根·巴斯弗罗恩德现在叫杰克·巴斯。他住在阿拉巴马州的伯明翰，我去那里找他谈谈他在离开欧洲前遇到的那位老教授。
I remember that a lady from Nuremberg. She was old. She certainly wouldn't be alive today anymore. She told me about Dr. Boder. I went in there because he wants to he hear stories. And I think that I looked for him. I mean I knew where he was, and that I introduced myself. And that's how the interview took place.
我记得那是来自纽伦堡的一位女士。她年纪很大了。她今天肯定不在人世了。她告诉了我关于博德博士的事。我去了那里，因为他想听听故事。我想我是去找他的。我的意思是，我知道他在哪，然后我做了自我介绍。这就是采访进行的方式。
Were you facing him?
你是面对着他吗？
I think that we sat across a table from each other. And the recorder was on the table, I believe. I remember it was a red, [? Webcoa ?] wire recorder. And of course it was some kind of a miracle in those days because that you could actually have a tape, a wire that would record your words was something that I hadn't seen before.
我想我们是隔着桌子坐的。我相信录音机就在桌子上。我记得那是一台红色的线录音机。当然，在那几天这简直是个奇迹，因为你能真正拥有一盘磁带、一根能记录你话语的线，是我以前没见过的。
You would think that a researcher talking to refugees after the war, a psychologist of all people, would show the appropriate sensitivity. But that's not exactly the way things went. One survivor was so upset by Boder's aloofness that she still refuses to have her interview published. And as Bass remembers, Boder might as well have been asking directions.
你会认为一位战后与难民交谈的研究人员，还是个心理学家，会表现出应有的敏感度。但事情并非如此。一位幸存者对博德的冷漠感到非常沮丧，以至于她至今拒绝公布她的采访。正如巴斯所记得的，博德当时问问题的样子就好像在问路。
I still see him interviewing me, and he was stern. He looked at me, and he had a very serious expression on his face. And he would say to me, "And what happened after you left Auschwitz? And where did you end up after Auschwitz? And where did you go? And what did you have to eat?" He was a thorough interviewer, but he was very stern.
我依然能看到他采访我时的样子，他很严厉。他看着我，脸上表情非常严肃。他会对我说：“你离开奥斯威辛后发生了什么？离开奥斯威辛后你到了哪里？你去了哪里？你吃了什么？”他是一位彻底的采访者，但他非常严厉。
And then they cut our hair with a razor.
然后他们用剃刀剪掉了我们的头发。
With an electric razor?
是用电动剃刀吗？
Yes.
是的。
They sheared you essentially.
他们基本上把你剪光了。
[INAUDIBLE] shaved.
[听不清]刮了。
Tell me, who did the shearing?
告诉我，是谁执行的剪发？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
[听不清]
Men or women?
男人还是女人？
Women.
女人。
Your hair from the head?
头上的头发？
Everything.
一切。
Your whole body?
全身吗？
Yes, the whole body.
是的，全身。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] Why did they do that?
[听不清]他们为什么要那样做？
I can't tell you.
我不能告诉你。
It was a formal, I think, somewhat like a teacher at a final exam. You can't look left or right. You just look at him and make sure that you don't look at anything else. But I was used to ti because in Europe, all the teachers are like that.
我认为这很正式，有点像期末考试时的老师。你不能左看右看。你只需看着他，并确保你没看别处。但我习惯了，因为在欧洲，所有的老师都是那样的。
In his two months in Europe, Boder went from a passing acquaintance with Nazi atrocities to knowing probably as much as anyone alive. But it wasn't until the very end that cracks appeared in his customary reserve. So Hara Bass is the head librarian at the Illinois Institute of Technology and currently running a project to restore and archive Boder's work. She remembers the moment in the tapes when she heard the change, an interview in Yiddish with a Polish woman named Anna Kavitska.
在欧洲的两个月里，博德从对纳粹暴行略知一二到可能了解得和任何活着的人一样多。但直到最后，他平时的矜持才出现了裂痕。所以哈拉·巴斯是伊利诺伊理工学院的首席图书管理员，目前正在运行一个修复和归档博德工作的项目。她记得在磁带中听到变化的时刻，那是对一位名叫安娜·卡维茨卡的波兰女性的意第绪语采访。
It was the less interview he interviewed. And the person in the story was talking about her daughter, which was a newborn that she had to leave in the street, in this snow, for a Christian lady in Poland to pick her up so she can take her to the orphanage. And we're talking about a newborn, and it was 25 degree below. There was snow on the ground. She left the child in the street. This woman had seen most of her family perish, and had not gotten to see her daughter after her birth.
那是他采访的最后一次。故事中的人正在谈论她的女儿，一个她不得不留在街头雪地里，让波兰的一位基督教女士捡起带去孤儿院的新生儿。我们说的是一个新生儿，当时气温零下25度。地上有雪。她把孩子留在了街上。这个女人目睹了她大部分家人死亡，而且在她出生后也没能再见到她的女儿。
[SPEAKING YIDDISH]
[说意第绪语]
This person was sobbing throughout the interview. And it just seems after he listened to 109 people, it weighed very heavy on him at that point. I was able to hear the sadness, his impatience with the very last story in a way, I have had it. I have heard enough.
这个人整个采访过程中都在啜泣。在听了109个人之后，这一点似乎让他感到沉重。我能听到那种悲伤，听到他对这最后一个故事的不耐烦，就好像是，“够了，我听得够多了。”
[SPEAKING YIDDISH]
[说意第绪语]
Well, we have to conclude. My automobile is waiting. That's how we miss very valuable material if I have to cancel another appointment. [UNINTELLIGIBLE], September of '46 in the synagogue they first desecrated in 1937 or 1937, and which has its holiday service for the first time today and donors here to re-dededicate it. What he have heard from this woman is about the story we have heard from everybody. I'm concluding my project in Germany. And I want to thank the owner, Jack Thompson from The Chicago Tribune.
嗯，我们得结束了。我的汽车在等着。如果我必须取消另一个预约，我们就会错过非常有价值的资料。[听不清]，46年9月，在1937年或1938年首次被亵渎的犹太教堂，今天第一次举行节日礼拜，捐赠者在这里进行重新奉献。你们从这位女性那里听到的就是我们从每个人那里听到的故事。我正在结束我在德国的项目。我想感谢物主，芝加哥论坛报的杰克·汤普森。
Boder wobbles back and forth here. On one side, a promoter scholar making his acknowledgement, on the other, an exhausted man shaken by what he's heard.
博德在这里摇摆不定。一边是正在致谢的推动者学者，另一边是听了这些故事后感到动摇、筋疲力尽的人。
And I can't speak. I don't remember the names now because I'm just in a trance after this woman's report. I'm completely distraught. The automobile is waiting. I'm going to Frankfurt. Who is going to sit in judgement over all this? And who is going to judge my work? Illinois Institute of Technology via recording. I'm leaving tonight for Paris. The project is concluded.
我没法说话。我现在不记得名字了，因为在那个女人的报告后我陷入了一种恍惚。我彻底崩溃了。汽车在等着。我要去法兰克福。谁来评判这一切？谁来评判我的工作？伊利诺伊理工学院通过录音。我今晚去巴黎。项目结束了。
You can read almost anything into that final, "who will judge my work?" The shame reporters feel when they hold the camera on someone in tears, the desire for recognition, the realization that his achievement consists of making people relive their worst moments. And the hope that documenting this tragedy might alleviate any guilt he might have felt about living in America while his relatives died at the hands of the Nazis. Boder spoke these words in English so that the woman would not understand, and he never included them in the transcript.
你可以对那最后的“谁来评判我的工作？”做出任何解读。记者在拍摄泪流满面的人时感受到的羞耻，对认可的渴望，意识到他的成就在于让人们重温他们最糟糕的时刻。以及希望记录这场悲剧能减轻他因生活在美国而他的亲人在纳粹手中死亡可能感到的任何负罪感。博德用英语说了这些话，这样那个女人就不会明白，他从未将它们包含在文字记录中。
Something happened when he came back. His promoter's instinct failed him just when he needed it the most. He never got enough money to transcribe all his interviews. He had hoped to put them in a book, but in the end, he published only eight out of the 109. And the book, I Did Not Interview The Dead, sold poorly and went out of print.
他回来时发生了些什么。他的推广本能在最需要它的时候失败了。他从未获得足够的资金来转录他所有的采访。他曾希望把它们整理成书，但最后，他只发表了109个中的8个。而那本书《我没有采访死者》，销量不佳并绝版了。
He followed his daughter to the west coast in 1952, and was offered a position as an unpaid research associate at UCLA. With the grant money running out, Boder kept transcribing the recordings on his own. I picture him alone in his office, playing and replaying passages to filter words from the noise, visited occasionally by his daughter Elena. Here he was in the new world, but immersed again in the old. After a life of moving on, moving out, moving up, Boder was back where he started.
他于1952年追随女儿去了西海岸，并获得了一个加州大学洛杉矶分校无薪研究助理的职位。随着资助金用完，博德继续自己转录录音。我想象他独自在他的办公室里，一遍又一遍地播放段落以过滤噪音中的词语，偶尔有他的女儿埃琳娜探访。他就在这里，在新世界，但又沉浸在旧世界中。在经历了一生的前进、搬迁、攀升之后，博德回到了他开始的地方。
I remember the tapes being in one area in this little library in the late '60's or '70's even. Queries came in to the department asking about the tapes, and they had disappeared. They were gone.
我记得在60年代末或70年代，这些磁带在这一小图书馆的某个区域。部门收到了询问磁带的查询，它们消失了。它们不见了。
Irving Maltzman was a young psychologist at UCLA when Boder first arrived, and he was in charge of the reading room of the Psychology Department there.
欧文·马尔茨曼是博德刚到洛杉矶分校时的一位年轻心理学家，他负责那里心理学系的阅览室。
I just think we just didn't realize the historical significance of them. In part, when he published it, there were still-- I think people had enough of the terrible stories that had appeared in the newspaper finally. And in part, it was because he was not some public celebrity. There was a lack of publicity and acclamation of the work at the time. And so it was just sitting in a little reading room in a psychology department, rather than in the Smithsonian Institute or the Holocaust Museum or something.
我只是认为我们当时没有意识到它们具有的历史意义。在某种程度上，当他出版它时，还有——我认为人们已经受够了报纸上出现的那些可怕故事。在某种程度上，是因为他不是什么公众名人。当时对这项工作缺乏宣传和赞誉。所以它只是静静地待在心理学系的一个小阅览室里，而不是在史密森学会或大屠杀博物馆之类的地方。
The term, the Holocaust, came up during the Second World Congress of Jewish Studies in 1957 in Jerusalem. It caught on quickly among scholars and spread to the general public by the early '60's. Before then, back in the '40's, everybody had a different name for it. There recent catastrophe, the recent Jewish catastrophe, the disaster, even the permanent pogrom.
“大屠杀”这个术语是在1957年耶路撒冷举行的第二届犹太研究世界大会期间出现的。它在学者中迅速流行，并到60年代初传到了公众。在那之前，回到40年代，每个人都有不同的称呼。最近的灾难、最近的犹太灾难、那场祸事，甚至持续的大屠杀。
Boder died in 1961. He was 75, and if he'd have lived just a few more years, he might have found an audience. In the early '60's, people began the serious gathering of recorded oral histories. As they looked around for survivors and testimonials, a set of wire spools sat unnoticed, Raiders of the Lost Ark style, inside wooden crates in a place called the Jefferson Technical Complex in the Library of Congress. The spools were copies of the originals, made by Boder himself and sent to the library in the '50's. Library staffers who asked about the crates were told they contained recordings of, quote, "people who had psychological problems as a result of being displaced during the war."
博德于1961年去世。他75岁，如果他能多活几年，他也许就能找到听众。在60年代初，人们开始认真收集录制的口述历史。当他们寻找幸存者和证言时，一叠线轴被无人注意地放置在国会图书馆一个名为杰斐逊技术大楼的地方的木箱里，那种像《夺宝奇兵》里的场景。这些线轴是博德本人制作并于50年代寄给图书馆的原始副本。当图书馆工作人员询问这些箱子时，他们被告知里面装的是“由于战争期间流离失所而产生心理问题的人们”的录音。
It wasn't until the mid 1990's that anyone figured out what the recordings were. A third of Boder's interviews have still never been transcribed.
直到90年代中期才有人弄清楚这些录音到底是什么。博德的三分之一采访至今仍未转录。
Carl Marziali in Chicago. If you want to hear David Boder's recordings, or read transcripts, there's a link to the official IIT website, Voices of the Holocaust, from the This American Life website, www.thisamericanlife.org.
芝加哥的卡尔·马齐亚利。如果你想听大卫·博德的录音，或阅读文字记录，可以从《美国生活》网站www.thisamericanlife.org获取官方IIT网站《大屠杀的声音》的链接。
Coming up, if your mom bites you in the tuckus, what's the name for that? Is that love? What if she breaks a plate over your head? Love? Is that love? Answers in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如果你的妈妈咬了你的屁股，那叫什么名字？那是爱吗？如果她把盘子砸在你头上呢？爱？那叫爱吗？几分钟后，在节目继续时，从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台为您揭晓。
It's This American Life.. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on the theme. Today's program, Before It Had A Name, stories of things in that delicate moment before we know exactly what they are. And how those things change once we pin a name onto to them. Things like, for example, Axis of Evil, a perfect example. Sure, North Korea, Iraq and Iran, they were bad before we pinned the name Axis of Evil onto those countries. But the name changed things, changed things for them. It turns out that part of what made North Korea so angry lately is being included on that list, is being called evil. Names matter.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给您各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《在它拥有名字之前》，讲述了那些在事物拥有确切定义前的微妙时刻的故事。以及一旦我们给它们贴上名字，事情如何改变。比如，举个例子，“邪恶轴心”，一个完美的例子。当然，朝鲜、伊拉克和伊朗，在我们给这些国家贴上“邪恶轴心”的标签之前，它们就很坏。但名字改变了事情，为它们改变了事情。事实证明，朝鲜最近之所以如此愤怒，部分原因是被列入那份名单，被贴上邪恶的标签。名字很重要。
Well we've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two is about that moment when we suddenly learn the name of something that has, up until that point, remain unnamed for us. When the name penetrate into us, the person or the place or the thing has penetrated into us too, I think. And if that doesn't seem to true to you, Heather O'Neill provides these real-life case studies.
嗯，我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕是关于那个我们突然得知某样东西的名字的时刻，在此之前，它对我们来说一直是无名的。当名字渗入我们体内时，我认为那个人、那个地方或那个东西也渗入了我们。如果这听起来对你来说不真实，希瑟·奥尼尔提供了一些现实生活案例研究。
I didn't know who Paul [? Rayon ?] was until he crashed on his motor scooter in front of the school, and he became the first person we ever saw killed. I had never heard of Sunny Teasedale until Mary Lou showed me the hickeys on her neck. I thought this guy was just a goon until I heard him singing "Panis Angelicus" with a cigarette in his mouth. Then I knew his name was Johnny Delorio for the rest of my life.
在保罗·雷恩在学校前开着摩托车摔倒之前，我不知道他是谁，他成了我们见过第一个被杀的人。在玛丽·卢给我看她脖子上的吻痕之前，我从未听说过桑尼·蒂斯代尔。我以为这家伙只是个暴徒，直到我听到他叼着烟唱《天使之粮》。那时起，我就记住了他的名字叫约翰尼·德洛里奥，终生不忘。
I didn't know Casper James until my uncle was buried at his parents' funeral parlor. "Hi," he said in the lobby. "We go to school together." Linda Hall was just a girl with a missing finger until she taught me all the words to a Sly and the Family Stone song at the swimming pool. He was from Africa, and he was cute. I wrote Chemewe down on a piece of paper so that I could practice it and stop asking him what his name was. He said his mother with Suzanne, from the Leonard Cohen song, but I could never remember his name.
直到我叔叔在卡斯帕·詹姆斯的父母经营的殡仪馆被埋葬前，我不知道卡斯帕·詹姆斯是谁。“嗨，”他在大厅里说，“我们一起上学。”琳达·霍尔只是个少了一根手指的女孩，直到她在游泳池教我斯莱和斯通家族乐队那首歌的歌词。他来自非洲，而且很可爱。我把他的名字写在纸条上，这样我就能练习，不用再问他叫什么名字。他说他母亲叫苏珊，来自莱昂纳德·科恩的那首歌，但我总是记不住他的名字。
"That's Quincy," they said, pointing to the boy on the high diving board who was afraid to jump. And every one yelled in unison, "Jump, jump, jump." Natasha wasn't really Natasha until she told me that her father hadn't been home for three days, and she slept on the balcony when it was warm. The teacher held up the math test that said Vladimir at the top of the page. In all the slots for answers, he had drawn pictures of guns. I looked at Vladimir sitting way in the corner. I didn't even think of him as having a name.
“那是昆西，”他们指着高台上不敢跳水的男孩说。每个人齐声喊道：“跳、跳、跳。”娜塔莎在告诉我她父亲已经三天没回家、天暖和时她睡在阳台上之前，并不是真正的娜塔莎。老师举起一张试卷顶端写着弗拉基米尔的数学试卷。在所有回答栏里，他画的是枪的图片。我看着坐在角落里的弗拉基米尔。我甚至没想过他是有名字的人。
I never knew Zero's real name. He sold heroin on Madison Avenue. Everyone started calling him Zero because just saying his real name would supposedly bring you bad luck. The neighborhood took away his name so they could feel a little more safe.
我从来不知道“零”的真名。他在麦迪逊大道卖海洛因。大家都开始叫他“零”，因为据说只要说出他的真名就会给你带来厄运。邻居们剥夺了他的名字，这样他们就能感到稍微安全一点。
My dad could never remember names, so every actor he didn't like on television he called, the child molester, or a degenerate. I would say, "The with the Italian pedophile is coming on." And he would hurry to the living room. My dad said he never paid for anything smaller than his fist. He used to tuck a gun in his boxer shorts when he took out the garbage because he said there could be rats out there. He got a license so that he could sell flowers on the corner downtown. The name on the license said Leonard O'Neill. Who the hell is that, I thought? Everybody I ever met called my dad, Buddy.
我爸爸总是记不住名字，所以他电视里不喜欢的每个演员他都叫“那个猥亵儿童者”或者“堕落者”。我会说：“那个意大利恋童癖的节目要开始了。”他就会匆匆忙忙赶到客厅。我爸说他从不付比他拳头小的东西的钱。他倒垃圾时会把枪塞进平角裤里，因为他说外面可能有老鼠。他拿到了执照，这样他就能在市中心的街角卖花。执照上的名字是伦纳德·奥尼尔。那到底是谁啊，我想？我认识的每个人都叫我爸“巴迪”。
My dad called me Dumbo because he said I had big ears. My mother called me Sputnik because my eyes were so big. My dad named me heather after a woman who taught him to read after he dropped out of school when he was in grade three. So that was my first name, and for a long time my middle name was Who. I had countless last names like, Heather who use to go out with Derek. Heather who kissed Marco at the dance. Heather who told Jeremy that her name was butterfly. Heather who had her shoes stolen in the park. Heather who wears that ugly blue ski jacket. Heather who has a sister in juvie. Heather who has a dad who used to rob banks. Heather who thinks she's better than every one because she says she was reincarnated.
我爸叫我“小飞象”，因为他说我耳朵大。我妈叫我“斯普特尼克”，因为我眼睛大。我爸给我起名叫希瑟，取自一个他在三年级辍学后教他阅读的女人。所以那是我的第一个名字，很长一段时间我的中间名是“谁”。我无数个姓氏比如：和德里克出去过的希瑟；在舞会上亲过马科的希瑟；告诉杰里米她名字是蝴蝶的希瑟；在公园鞋子被偷的希瑟；穿着那件丑蓝色滑雪夹克的希瑟；在少管所有个姐妹的希瑟；有个抢银行爸爸的希瑟；因为说自己是转世投胎而认为自己比谁都强的希瑟。
When you get your name, you are just a little baby and have no say about the matter. Your parents could get your name from anywhere. You could have a name that comes from an ugly relative or out of the Bible. It could be something they heard shouted out at the swimming pool. It could be the Spanish name for a bird, a strange name, a name your parents spelled wrong and no one could ever say right. Still, when people learn your name, they think they know all about you.
当你得到你的名字时，你只是个小婴儿，对此毫无决定权。你的父母可以从任何地方给你起名字。你可能拥有一个来自丑陋亲戚的名字，或者出自《圣经》。它可能是他们听到的在游泳池被大声呼喊的名字。它可能是西班牙语里鸟的名字、一个奇怪的名字，一个你父母拼错且没人能读对的名字。尽管如此，当人们知道你的名字时，他们认为他们已经了解了关于你的一切。
When my uncle sent me a pair of running shoes from Virginia, I wrote my name on the sides of both sneakers so no one could steal them from my locker. "Hi Heather," the man across for me in the bus said. It shocked me how he said, "Hi, Heather," like he knew me all his life. I'd seen him around, chasing pigeons and trying to pour beer on little kids in the park. I wanted to reach across the bus aisle and punch him in the face for knowing my name. Heater O'Neill is the author of Two Eyes Are You Sleeping, a book of poetry.
当我叔叔从弗吉尼亚寄给我一双运动鞋时，我在两只鞋子的侧面都写了我的名字，这样就不会有人从我的储物柜里偷走它们。“嗨，希瑟，”坐在公交车对面的人说。他那种“嗨，希瑟”的说法让我震惊，就好像他认识了我一辈子。我见过他在公园里追赶鸽子，试图往小孩身上泼啤酒。我想隔着公交车过道伸手去打他的脸，就因为他知道我的名字。希瑟·奥尼尔是《两只眼睛在睡觉》的作者，这是一本诗集。
[MUSIC - "WHAT'S MY NAME" BY BRIC-A-BRAC]
[音乐 - 布里克-阿-布拉克的《我叫什么》]
Act Three, A Bad Day For Plates. Laura Tangusso has this story about how things changed in her life, and in her whole family's life actually, when events in their past that they interpreted one way suddenly got a different name.
第三幕，《盘子倒霉的一天》。劳拉·坦古索讲述了这个故事，关于当他们过去一直以某种方式解读的事件突然有了不同的定义时，她的生活，实际上是她整个家庭的生活，发生了怎样的改变。
All my life, I thought my mother was difficult and crazy. My brother and sisters did too. That's how we thought of her for decades until recently, when we learned that there was a very different explanation for why she acted the way she did. We all have memories of craziness. Here are my sisters Leslie and Liz, and my brother John.
我这辈子一直认为我的母亲很难相处而且疯疯癫癫的。我的兄弟姐妹们也这么认为。几十年来我们一直这么看她，直到最近，我们才知道她行为怪异的原因有着非常不同的解释。我们都有关于疯狂的记忆。这是我的姐妹莱斯利和利兹，还有我的兄弟约翰。
I think I might have been in kindergarten. I went in the kitchen and she had broken all the dishes, just broken things everywhere. She was just breaking them. She just really lost it.
我想我当时可能在上幼儿园。我走进厨房，她打破了所有的盘子，到处都是破碎的东西。她就在那摔盘子。她真的崩溃了。
She picked up a jar of relish, and she turned around and just whipped it, pitched it at the wall. And it smashed on the wall. And I just remember the relish dripping down the wall. And she was just doing her own thing. She was in her own little world.
她拿起一罐调味酱，转身直接用力扔向墙壁。它在墙上撞得粉碎。我只记得调味酱顺着墙壁往下滴。她只是在做她自己的事。她活在她自己的小世界里。
I remember being older in high school, and being at mom's. And she lost her comb, and she just was crying and angry. And I remember really consoling and saying, "Mom, you know, it's a comb. Here, it's right here." And I felt so bad.
我记得在高中年纪大一点的时候，在妈妈家。她弄丢了梳子，她又哭又生气。我记得我还在安慰她说：“妈，你知道，那只是把梳子。你看，它不就在这儿吗。”我感觉很糟。
Mom went into a tirade about something and took a plate, a full-sized dinner plate, and whacked me on the top of his head. And I quickly left the house. And I remember sitting on a stone wall, pretty upset and stunned by what had happened. And I felt this warm sensation on the back of my neck, and I reached back with my hand. And I was actually bleeding from my skull. It wasn't serious that it required stitches or anything, but Mom did draw blood as they say.
妈妈因为某件事开始长篇大论地抱怨，然后拿起一个盘子，一个全尺寸的晚餐盘，狠狠地砸在哥哥的头顶上。我迅速离开了家。我记得坐在石墙上，因为刚才发生的事情感到非常不安和震惊。我感觉到脖子后面有一种温暖的感觉，我就用手摸了一下。原来我的头骨正在出血。虽然没严重到需要缝针什么的，但就像人们说的那样，妈妈确实让我流血了。
What made my mother confusing though was that she had another side of her. She was smart. She was adventurous. She took us to the original production of Hair in London. When I was 13 years old, she told me to read The Autobiography of Malcolm x. It's a book I still have. She had friends who thought she was a real character and fun. And even some of our friends thought she was cool.
然而，让我妈感到困惑的是，她还有另一面。她很聪明。她很有冒险精神。她带我们去伦敦看了《毛发》的原版制作。我13岁时，她让我读《马尔科姆·X自传》。那本书我至今留着。她有朋友认为她是个真实有个性且有趣的人。甚至我们的一些朋友也认为她很酷。
But for us, things always felt precarious, on the brink. She was unpredictable. She could be scary, and we all tried in our own ways to protect ourselves and make things normal. Being the oldest, I would try to keep the house in order, thinking somehow that would keep my mother in order. My sisters spent as much time as they could out of the house. Leslie once asked my parents if she could live with another family. I remember how when my sister was young, when she got upset she'd hold her breath until she passed out. I always figured this was her own special way of escaping.
但对我们来说，一切总是感觉岌岌可危，处于边缘。她难以预测。她可能很吓人，我们都以各自的方式尝试保护自己，让事情变得正常。作为长女，我总是尽量让家里井井有条，认为那样能让我的母亲也井井有条。我的姐妹们尽量花时间待在屋外。莱斯利曾经问我的父母她是否可以和另一个家庭一起生活。我记得当我妹妹还小的时候，当她生气时，她会屏住呼吸直到晕倒。我一直认为这是她逃避现实的特殊方式。
By the time we were adults, we'd all decided to keep our distance from her. None of us lived far away, but we'd easily go three, four months, or much longer, without seeing her. When we did see her, it was usually because we initiated it, not her. It was as if it just never occurred to her to make connections with her family. I remember once I was babysitting my niece and nephew, and I took them to pick up my mother so we could all do something together. When my mother got in the car, my nephew, who was four at the time, looked at me and asked, "Who's she?"
当我们成年后，我们都决定和她保持距离。我们离得都不远，但我们很容易三四个月甚至更久不去看她。当我们见到她时，通常是因为我们主动发起，而不是她。好像她根本就没想过要和家人建立联系。我记得有一次我在照顾我的侄子和侄女，我带他们去接我的母亲，这样我们就能聚在一起做点什么。当我的母亲上车时，当时才四岁的侄子看着我问：“她是哪位？”
It was a family joke about my mother, that if she was this bad now, just wait until she got old. And in fact, when she reached her 70's, and her health began to decline, she became a kind of nightmare. She had become severely arthritic and frail, but lied about seeing doctors and resented our efforts to assist her. To make things worse, she also started losing her memory. By the time she'd had a second hip surgery, she had become so confusing and agitated, she slugged a nurse. We weren't that shocked, but the hospital took it seriously, and she was sent to a psych unit.
关于我母亲，家庭里有个笑话：如果她现在就这样，等她老了会变成什么样。事实上，当她到了70岁，健康开始恶化时，她成了一种噩梦。她患有严重的关节炎，身体虚弱，但却谎报医生看病的情况，并对我们提供的帮助感到不满。更糟糕的是，她还开始失去记忆。到她做第二次髋关节手术时，她变得如此困惑和烦躁，竟然殴打了一名护士。我们对此并不太震惊，但医院认真对待了这件事，她被送进了精神病区。
The doctors there did some routine CAT scans, what we were then told was so amazing it took months to fully absorb. On New Year's Eve of 1999, six months after hearing that report, I began recording my and my siblings' reactions.
那里的医生做了一些常规的CAT扫描，我们被告知的内容之惊人，以至于花了几个月才完全吸收。1999年的新年前夜，在听到那份报告六个月后，我开始录下我和兄弟姐妹们的反应。
When the doctors heard our descriptions of her behavior, combined with what they saw her scans, they said that it was very possible that she has had some brain damage most of her life. And I think that for me-- I don't know but I think maybe too for my sisters and brothers, that was just one of the most stunning moments in all of this for me because all my life I just thought that my mother was just difficult. That's the way she was. I just thought she was just that way. But when I heard it from someone else, and when they said they had even physical evidence of it, it just changed things in an instant.
当医生听到我们对她行为的描述，结合他们在扫描中看到的，他们说她很可能一生大部分时间都有脑损伤。我想对我来说——我不知道，但我想对我的姐妹兄弟们来说也是如此——这是我一生中最令人震惊的时刻之一，因为我这辈子一直认为我的母亲只是很难相处。她就是那样的人。我只是认为她就是那样。但当我从别人那里听到它，而且他们说甚至有生理证据时，事情瞬间就改变了。
The CAT scans showed that my mother has frontal lobe syndrome, which is a shrinkage of the frontal lobe of the brain. She may have been born with it, or it may have been the result of some childhood illness or accident. In any event, for as long as we've known her, she's had it.
CAT扫描显示我的母亲患有额叶综合征，这是大脑额叶萎缩。她可能是天生的，或者是某种童年疾病或事故的结果。总之，只要我们认识她，她就一直患有这种病。
Just with that diagnosis, there's a sense of relief because it's no longer an unknown. Prior to that, I think that I wrote mom off as being a very malicious person. And I just used to think that there was a nasty side of her personality that she was in control of. And I guess that was what I learned, is that the bad side of her personality was not necessarily something that she was in control of.
仅仅有了这个诊断，就有一种解脱感，因为它不再是未知的了。在此之前，我认为我把妈妈定性为一个非常恶毒的人。我总是认为她性格中有那种她能控制的丑陋一面。我想我学到的是，她性格中坏的那一面并不一定是由她控制的。
It was an enormous thing to take in. She'd always been a mystery that we never imagined we'd understand. She'd done so many things that were confusing and scary. She'd blow up at such small things, like when my brother put too much soap in the sink. My mother got so enraged she put them in his room, said he was sick and threatened to send him to an institution. Suddenly, it didn't seem all her fault.
这是一件需要巨大心理承载的事。她一直是个我们从未想过能理解的谜。她做了那么多让人困惑和恐惧的事情。她会因为琐碎的小事爆发，比如当我哥哥在水槽里放了太多肥皂时。我母亲被激怒到把他关在房间里，说他生病了，并威胁要把他送进精神病院。突然之间，这似乎并不全是她的错。
My mother was put on medications, which slowly began to help her. She stopped being antagonistic. She showed appreciation for us and the staff, and she acted gracious in ways I had never seen before. After a month and a half in the psych hospital, she was moved into a nursing home. But by then, she was experiencing serious memory, and I felt like I was both gaining and losing a mother at the same time.
我母亲开始服用药物，这慢慢开始有所帮助。她不再具有对抗性。她对我们和工作人员表示感谢，她的表现出的优雅是我从未见过的。在精神病院住了一个半月后，她被送进了疗养院。但到那时，她正在经历严重的记忆力减退，我觉得我好像在失去母亲的同时又获得了一个母亲。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃声]
Hello.
喂。
Mom.
妈。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi, it's Laurie.
嗨，我是劳瑞。
I know. Hi, how are you?
我知道。嗨，你好吗？
Good, how are you?
挺好，你呢？
Fine, thank you.
很好，谢谢。
So it's your birthday this weekend.
所以这周末是你的生日。
It's my birthday?
是我的生日？
Yep, March 5.
是啊，3月5日。
Good lord, I forgot all about it.
天啊，我都忘了这回事了。
Sunday.
周日。
Sunday. And how old am I going to be on Sunday. Let's see. Oy, something I'd rather not think about.
周日。那周日我要多大了？让我想想。哎呀，我宁愿不想这个。
You can hear that my mother is losing her memory, but when I listen to this conversation, what strikes me most is the ease in our voices, how normal we sound, the way my mother laughs at herself.
你能听到我母亲正在失去记忆，但当我听这段对话时，最打动我的是我们声音里的轻松，我们听起来多么正常，母亲嘲笑自己的方式。
I mean mom hugged me three times today, kissed me goodbye twice, thanked me so very much for what a great day. And I don't remember mom ever saying that stuff. We got this six to eight week window of mom being Mrs. Wonderful. I mean she just couldn't have been any more upbeat or radiant and fun to be around and laughing. And just looking so much better, and having good color in her skin. She had put on weight. I mean I hadn't seen mom wear makeup in a bazillion years, fixing her hair. And it was just really sad because I'm thinking, wow, what would life have been if mom had been this person when I was growing up?
我是说，妈妈今天拥抱了我三次，吻着跟我说了两次再见，非常感谢我让她度过了愉快的一天。我不记得妈妈曾经说过那些话。我们得到了这段妈妈是“美妙女士”的六到八周窗口期。我的意思是她简直再乐观、再光芒四射、再好相处不过了，一直在笑。看起来气色好多了，脸色红润。她增重了。我是说我好久没看到妈妈化妆、打理头发了。这真的很悲伤，因为我在想，哇，如果我成长时妈妈就是这样的人，生活会是怎样？
It's made us all wonder what would she have been like. Maybe she would have stayed married to my father. Maybe she would have published one of the books she wrote instead of destroying everyone. And maybe it wouldn't be so remarkable to us now when she behaves in normal ways. It's also hard not to wonder about how we would have been different. Would there be more grandchildren? Would one of us be a published novelist? Would we be happier? But of course, these are possible questions.
这让我们都在想她会是什么样子。也许她会和我父亲保持婚姻。也许她会出版她写的书而不是摧毁一切。也许她现在的正常行为对我们来说就不会那么引人注目了。同样难以不去想我们会有什么不同。会有更多孙辈吗？我们会有人成为出版小说家吗？我们会更幸福吗？但当然，这些都是假设性的问题。
Mom did a lot things that affected my childhood, and I'll never forgive her.
妈妈做了很多影响我童年的事情，我永远不会原谅她。
Of all my siblings, my sister Leslie may have had the most difficult relationship with my mother. Leslie is the youngest, and was the only one who ever lived alone with her. There was no one else around to cushion her from my mother's craziness, and as soon as she finished high school, Leslie joined the army to get herself away.
在我的兄弟姐妹中，我的妹妹莱斯利可能与我母亲的关系最艰难。莱斯利是最小的，也是唯一一个曾经和母亲单独住在一起的人。没有别人在身边让她免受母亲疯狂行为的困扰，而且莱斯利一中学毕业就参军离开。
It was very stressful, very confusing for me to go through a lot of change that she put me through. And I understand that she was probably sick at the time, but I don't know. I guess I just haven't worked through it enough.
经历她强加给我的那些巨大变化，真的压力很大，也很让人困惑。我知道她当时可能病了，但我也说不清。我想我只是还没完全走出来。
She asked me once how my childhood was. "Did you have a happy childhood?" was how she phrased it. We were just out, and we were at a restaurant eating. And we just having a conversation about nothing of any great importance, just small talk I guess. And she just came out with this question. Maybe she was lucid at that moment, and she just needed to know. And I told her I did.
有一次她问我童年过得怎么样。“你有一个快乐的童年吗？”她是这样问的。我们当时刚好在外面，在一家餐馆吃饭。我们只是在随便聊些无关紧要的事，我想只是闲聊。她突然冒出这个问题。也许那一刻她很清醒，她只是需要知道。我告诉她我过得很幸福。
The other night, I went to visit my mother at the nursing home. As we were leaving her floor to go out to dinner, my mother wanted to stop by the activities room to say goodbye to some friends. A man named Patrick, who's in a wheelchair and can't speak very well, called out in his slow voice, "Hello Dorothy." My mother looked directly at him, and in a loud, stern voice said, "And you, get out of that chair and take a walk for heaven's sake." For an instant, I cringed, flashing back to the countless times my mother was inappropriate in public. But then Patrick started laughing, and my mother started laughing. And as often happens now, I was reminded how much has changed.
前几天晚上，我去疗养院看望母亲。当我们离开楼层准备去吃晚饭时，我母亲想去活动室和一些朋友告别。一个坐在轮椅上、不太会说话的男人名叫帕特里克，用他缓慢的声音喊道：“你好，多萝西。”我母亲直视着他，大声而严厉地说：“还有你，从那张椅子上起来，看在上帝的份上走走。”那一瞬间，我畏缩了，闪回到我母亲在公共场合表现不得体的无数次场景。但随后帕特里克开始大笑，我母亲也开始大笑。正如现在经常发生的那样，我被提醒着一切改变了多少。
Laura Tangusso is a teacher and visual artist in Boston. This is her first story for the radio.
劳拉·坦古索是波士顿的一名教师和视觉艺术家。这是她为电台创作的第一个故事。
[MUSIC - "WHAT'S THE GOOD WORD" BY JACKIE REINACH/ MEL PORETZ]
[音乐 - 杰基·赖纳赫/梅尔·波雷茨的《好话是什么》]
Act Four, You Call That Love? Consider please the word, love. Love between mothers and children, love between spouses. Once the word is applied to a feeling, is it possible that we are not all referring to the same thing? Jonathan Goldstein has some thoughts about that question.
第四幕，《你管那叫爱？》。请思考一下“爱”这个词。母子之间的爱，配偶之间的爱。一旦这个词应用于一种感觉，我们是不是可能并没有指代同一样东西？乔纳森·戈德斯坦对这个问题有一些思考。
If there was no such word as love, our vocabulary would be richer, and we'd have to struggle harder to find the right words. Everyone would be so long winded and Shakespearean in their range of emotional expression. The word love came along and wiped out all sorts of terms in a semantical bloodbath.
如果根本没有“爱”这个词，我们的词汇会更丰富，我们必须更努力地寻找正确的词汇。每个人在情感表达的范围上都会变得那么冗长和像莎士比亚风格。而“爱”这个词出现，在一场语义大屠杀中抹杀了所有其他词汇。
Without the word love, people would speak in terms of sensations, like the sensation of standing waist-deep in a tub of warm plum sauce. Or the sensation of being tickled on the back of the knees. Some would say they felt like they had just swallowed a honey-soaked boxing glove, and others might say that they were feeling like their guts had been yanked out and spread across the kitchen floor.
没有“爱”这个词，人们会用感官来表达，比如站在半腰深的一桶温暖李子酱里的感觉。或者是膝盖后面被挠痒的感觉。有些人会说他们感觉刚吞下了一只浸透蜂蜜的拳击手套，而另一些人可能会说他们感觉肠子被掏出来铺在了厨房地板上。
Without the word love, you would get wedding invitations that would say things like, "On July 15, join us at the Five Holy Martyrs Church of Worship to help celebrate Barry Lyscinzy's feeling of aimless goodwill that he's decided to direct onto Robin Krupka, who's receptive to the idea of being with a man she's fairly certain will never inflict hurt on her."
没有“爱”这个词，你会收到写着类似这样的婚礼请柬：“7月15日，请加入我们在五位圣殉道者礼拜堂，共同庆祝巴里·莱斯金齐对自己决定投射到罗宾·克鲁普卡身上的那种漫无目的的善意所产生的感受，罗宾·克鲁普卡也愿意接受和一个她相当确定永远不会伤害她的男人在一起的想法。”
Sometimes we call something love because we don't know what else to call it. When I first started dating Holly, there was one night where I was double-riding her back home from downtown on my bike. And she kissed my neck and rubbed my back through my tee shirt. We were going uphill, and she knew I could use all the encouragement I could get. We had spent the evening with some friends we didn't especially like, just because we didn't have the heart to say no to them. "We should go out more often," she said from behind me. "The way I hate everybody makes me love you more." Was that a moment of love, or merely an instance of lack of hate?
有时我们称之为爱，因为我们不知道还能叫它什么。我刚开始和霍莉约会时，有一天晚上我骑车从市中心带她回家。她吻了我的脖子，隔着T恤摩擦我的背。我们正在上坡，她知道我需要得到所有能得到的鼓励。我们那天晚上和一些我们并不特别喜欢的朋友待在一起，只是因为我们不忍心拒绝他们。“我们应该多出去走走，”她在我身后说。“我憎恨每个人的方式让我更爱你。”那是爱的时刻，还是仅仅是缺乏恨意的例子？
With Christiane, I thought I couldn't be in love because her knees were too big. They were the size of grapefruits, and I could not see myself being in love with a woman whose knees were that big. They were ludicrous really. My thinking was that it was a good thing they were so ludicrous because they kept me firmly anchored. If I thought for even a second that I might be falling in love, all I had to do was think of those big, fat knees of hers, and then, one day, I found myself kissing them. I had to leap over a great inner hurdle to get to that, but it wasn't love that was on the other side. It was just self-congratulatory pats on my own back over how I could move beyond pettiness like that.
和克里斯蒂安在一起时，我以为我不可能坠入爱河，因为她的膝盖太大了。它们有葡萄柚那么大，我无法想象自己会爱上一个膝盖那么大的女人。它们真的荒唐可笑。我的想法是，它们那么荒唐其实是件好事，因为它们把我牢牢固定住了。如果我有一秒钟想到我可能会坠入爱河，我只需要想想她那双又大又肥的膝盖，然后，有一天，我发现自己在亲吻它们。我不得不跳过一个巨大的内心障碍才达到这一点，但那另一端并不是爱。那只是对自己如何能超越那种小气感到自满的自我拍拍背。
When I was 16, there was a summer I spent in Wildwood, New Jersey, where one night while walking down the boardwalk feeling lonely and depressed, a girl a few years older than me came spinning down the boardwalk, her arms spread out. She came right towards me, and then, when we were face to face, she kissed me. Just like that. Because she was drunk or stoned, but she had kissed me. For the rest of the summer, I couldn't pass a woman on the boardwalk without thinking that we should somehow be meeting in a kiss, that that's how life should really be.
我16岁时，有一个夏天是在新泽西州的怀尔德伍德度过的，那天晚上我走在木板路上，感到孤独和沮丧，一个比我大几岁的女孩张开双臂旋转着顺着木板路过来。她径直朝我走来，然后当我们面对面时，她吻了我。就是那样。因为她喝醉了或磕了药，但她吻了我。那个夏天的余下时间里，我无法经过木板路上的任何女人，而不想到我们应该以某种方式在接吻中相遇，那才是生活真正该有的样子。
In that moment, where our lips touched, the way it suddenly brought into alignment the private, unspeakable hopefulness in the heart with the uncontrollableness of the outside world, it felt like as surely as anything else I've ever experienced, a moment of love. I say this as an adult who has had serious relationship since, and I can't think of another word but love to describe what I felt that day on the boardwalk. And that was it. She just walked on.
在那一刻，当我们的嘴唇接触时，它突然将心中那种无法言喻的私密希望与外部世界的不可控性对齐，它感觉就像我经历过的任何其他事情一样确定，那是一个爱的时刻。作为成年后有过认真感情经历的人，我说这话时，我想不出除了“爱”之外的词来描述那天我在木板路上感受到的东西。就是那样。她只是走开了。
When I was a little kid, my mother's favorite things was to crane her head through a door frame or around a corner and bite me or my sister on the ass while explaining, "Boy, is this a tuckus." I spent much of my childhood walking around our house always on my guard, always feeling like she could strike at any moment. She was never really any good with words, so this was sort of her version of a love sonnet. At least that's how I've chosen to see it. You could also say it was filthy and damaging, but if you want to see something as love, or even need to see it as love, and you call it love, it feels a lot more like love.
我小时候，我母亲最喜欢做的事就是从门框或角落探出头，咬我和我妹妹的屁股，同时解释说：“天哪，这真是个屁股。”我童年的大部分时间都在我们家里走动，总是处于戒备状态，总是觉得她随时可能发起攻击。她从不擅长用言语，所以这算是她的“十四行诗”。至少我选择这样看待它。你也可以说这是肮脏和破坏性的，但如果你想把某事看作爱，或者甚至需要把它看作爱，而你称之为爱时，它感觉更像是爱了。
Jonathan Goldstein is one of the producers of our program and author of the great novel, Lenny Bruce Is Dead.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦是我们节目的制片人之一，也是伟大的小说《莱尼·布鲁斯已死》的作者。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Mr. Todd Bachmann and Diane Cook. Music help today from Mr. John Connors.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我自己制作的，还有温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩。高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼先生和黛安·库克提供了制作帮助。今天的音乐帮助来自约翰·康纳斯先生。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENT]
[鸣谢]
If you'd lke to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at the WBEZ in Chicago. Look it up in the book, or call 312-948-4680. Or visit our website where you can buy tapes. Or actually you can just listen to our programs for free online, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. [FUNDING CREDITS]
如果您想购买本节目或我们任何节目的盒带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ。在书中查询，或致电312-948-4680。或者访问我们的网站购买磁带。或者实际上你可以免费在线收听我们的节目，www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. Whenever I pass Torey in the hallway, he turns and whistles. And he says--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。每当我走廊里遇到托里，他都会转身吹口哨。他说——
Boy, is this a tuckus.
天哪，这真是个屁股。
Sure he does. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
他当然会这么说。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio international.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。